what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and it looks like fans
might have spotted a secret villain
hiding in one of the doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness trailers now i
personally think that there is a secret
villain to multiverse of madness that
hasn't been revealed yet or hasn't
really been talked about too much yet
and i'm gonna talk about it in this
video and of course if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest news let's dive
into it so this came out in the trailer
that marvel studios posted when tickets
went on sale for multiverse of madness
it was titled marvel studios is doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
dream and i actually think that what
we're about to look at is a face and i
think that there's a lot more to dissect
in this dream trailer now that we see
this face but let's take a look at this
it's literally in the very beginning of
this trailer it literally starts at zero
seconds the marvel studio logo comes
into the screen and what appears to be a
face a very menacing face starts to form
right below the studio logo in the
middle now this looks very intentional
and we know marvel studios is
intentional with pretty much everything
that they do if we take a look at the
rest of the background during this part
where the logo is showing we can see
that pretty much everything else seems
to be pretty random and this face seems
to be pretty clear so a lot of fans are
thinking that this is actually something
put in there very secretively to
represent a villain of the film and even
if you don't think that this is an
actual face even if you think that this
is just random lines that just so happen
to form a face i'm still going to be
going over different villains that could
be appearing in multiverse of madness
because it just makes sense i do believe
that there is a secret villain in
multiverse of madness that hasn't truly
been revealed yet now don't get me wrong
i still think that the scarlet witch is
the main villain of this film her and
another variant of herself i think are
going to be the main antagonist however
as i've been stating in my previous
videos i do think wanda is going to be
somewhat manipulated by someone or
something it could be another scarlet
witch variant that is manipulating her
one that is much more evil or there
could be another being out there like
c'thun given all the connections there
are many different villains that could
actually fit into multiverse of madness
very well that could be manipulated
wanda so let's talk about who these
villains could be pretty much it's
narrowed down to about three different
villains and here's the thing each of
these villains makes sense so it could
be either one of these villains now to
start off talking about marvel studios
hiding things in one of the first
posters that we got for multiverse of
madness the one with all of the
shattered pieces of glass fans did spot
a creature a monster a bean of some sort
in one of the pieces of glass that
wasn't really in any of the trailers at
that point in time it was a creature
that looked an awful lot like the comic
version of c'thun who was the first
villain that this very well could be now
in a trailer that was released later on
we go on to see not one but two beans
that look exactly the same that look
like this monster that is in the broken
piece of glass here and yet again this
monster now on screen looks an awful lot
like the comic version of c'thun and we
can't ignore the major connection that
wanda has to c'thun and the darkhold as
well we've talked about this many times
before on the channel but c'thun created
the darkhold c'thun was one of the
original gods of the universe but him
along with many other of the original
gods turned into essentially demons and
c'thun was learned in the magical arts
dark sorcery and he took everything that
he knew and he wrote it down on
indestructible parchment he put all of
the pages together and then bam the
darkhold was formed then not to mention
on wondergore mountain before he was
kicked out of the earth's realm right
before he left he touched an infant
child this child was wanda maximoff and
he imprinted upon her his chaos magic
and he intended on her to be a vessel
eventually for him to return a body for
him to possess which could be something
that is happening in multiverse of
madness now we know wanda she isn't evil
although she did enslave a whole town
but she didn't do it because she was an
evil being she did it because she was in
mourning now of course too much tragedy
can break somebody and wanda has been
through her fair share of tragedy which
kind of makes her vulnerable to
influence essentially and if you're
c'thun you're thinking this is the
perfect time to strike however i
actually think wanda might be too
powerful now for even c'thun i do think
that he could be influencing her but
then i think she's going to catch on to
what is actually happening then i think
she might actually kind of control him
and that could be what we're seeing in
these trailers that could be c'thun
except wanda might be in charge and not
him and as far as there being two of
these creatures well it's the multiverse
anything can happen we're gonna see a
lot of different variants of a lot of
different characters but of course there
are other villains that have major
connections to wanda and i'm gonna say
it i'm gonna say the m word mephisto yes
mephisto has kind of become somewhat of
a joke now but we really can't argue
that mephisto has major connections to
wanda especially her and her twins now
in one division wanda had her twins and
then they were taken away from her at
the end this is kind of similar to what
happens in the comics now the comics
wanda and vision have twins but vision's
an android so how exactly do they do
that well they say it was wanda's magic
that caused her to get pregnant
basically what happens in one division
however later on we go to find out that
these were actually pieces of mephisto's
soul wanda has the twins but eventually
mephisto takes them back and this is
kind of what sets wanda off on a really
bad path and this is actually the story
that we're seeing here in multiverse of
madness wanda is going on a killing
spree because she's doing whatever it
takes to get back her children marvel
studios made that very clear with their
last trailer that showed the twins in it
and here's a very interesting thing
about this trailer where we supposedly
see this face it starts off by showing
doctor strange looking at a pretty much
destroyed sanctum and the sanctum is
standing alone when he goes to the door
on the door we see two different faces
that kind of do look like mephisto if
not mephisto they definitely look like
another bean but let's keep in mind that
this trailer is titled dream but then
wanda says it's a nightmare and
nightmare is the third villain of who
the secret villain of this movie could
be i'm sure some of you remember that
the very first doctor strange film was
actually supposed to have nightmare as
the main villain this didn't happen
obviously dormammu was the main villain
but they decided that nightmare was
going to be the main villain of the
second film but that was with director
scott derrickson and as most people know
scott derrickson of marvel studios
parted ways and now sam raimi is
directing multiverse madness so that
very well could have changed but we do
know that a script was written for
doctor strange 2 that had nightmare as
the main villain and this trailer
definitely gives off major nightmare
vibes and wanda even says nightmare in
it you have to wonder why is doctor
strange having the same dream every
night why is wanda having the same dream
every night which is actually a
nightmare could it actually be the work
of nightmare could he be the villain
that is behind everything now again just
to reiterate i think eventually wanda
realizes that she's being influenced and
either becomes good or kind of embraces
the chaos here harnessing all the power
that she can to go and retrieve her
children to finally be at peace and this
is actually a pretty big debate right
now within the fandom if wanda is truly
the main villain in which we all believe
that she is how should the movie end
should it end with her becoming good
should she die or should whatever being
is possibly behind her be finally ripped
out of her and then her and doctor
strange go on to fight that bean i
definitely don't think that she is going
to die especially with all the rumors
going around that elizabeth olsen signed
a new contract with marvel and that
there's going to be more upcoming
scarlet witch projects but let me know
what you think you think there's another
villain hiding in multiverse of madness
that hasn't been revealed yet do you
think that this is a face i personally
think it looks like an evil group kind
of but let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest marvel
news for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
[Music]
me